so it's a pretty big deal to lead your
very first TV series so what is the best
piece of advice you got jumping into
headlining a you know a super high
profile Disney show but then also having
been through it now what piece of advice
would you give to someone else out there
about to do the same thing oh
um the best piece of advice I got in the
beginning
um
you know I think it was
the ability to make the character my own
um it was the you know it was
it gave me a lot to Branch out into and
it was the web release that I think a
lot for the you know they created the
character Jeff Valenzuela but they also
allowed me the Liberty to you know kind
of give my perspective on on certain
scenes um and they were always really
receptive of it and so I think for them
the advice that they gave was just
because I put my heart into it and they
knew how much I cared that they um
respected uh you know the process in
that way too and encouraged it and I'm
really grateful for that and then I'd
also say now looking back at it I'd give
uh the piece of advice that everything's
gonna be okay you know I think you never
I always like live by the idea that you
know you never know if there is going to
be a tomorrow so make the most of today
and I think in this instance you know
there are many many days of filming um
within those seven months and uh in that
time I grew a lot as a person
um similar to how Jess grew as a
character so you know I think just take
it day by day listen everything will be
okay I like that approach to everything
in life uh going back to something that
you just brought up in terms of your
influence on the character is there
anything specific that our viewers can
look out for that is like purely your
own wasn't on the page to begin with and
you're really proud of it and what
people take notice oh my goodness
um
okay well one moment that I'm really
proud of in general
um in episode three there was like a
seven page monologue
um that my character does and and the
scene she's translating for her for this
is a spoiler I'm so sorry uh she's
translating for somebody and uh it is um
I think in that sense she kind of you
know for me as an artist it was really
difficult to kind of have to stay in the
mindset of sticking to the dialogue but
also imagining on the scene what I was
seeing because my character was watching
something very special and um true to
her and her story and um yeah I was kind
of multitasking in that way and I think
for me I have a really strong connection
with my family so I added a lot of those
elements of how much she cares about the
treasure um because of that so it was it
was a lot of my own heart and and when
one particular scene that was a very
good example of running right to the
edge but stopping short um
we're okay guys we're okay very very
well done
um so I was watching that the I was
watching the interview that you did with
my colleague at Comic-Con and you were
talking about uh Catherine Zeta Jones
and you had brought up you know even on
your hardest days she was always there
to welcome you with open arms so that
was kind of just making me wonder can
you give us an example of a hard day on
set and maybe tell us what made it hard
and then how you overcame that challenge
absolutely
um you know the film process uh was just
taxing in general just because it was
really long shoot days
um and most of the days we were out in
the elements of the world so there was a
lot of heat and you know stress and TV
works and functions really quickly and
you have to keep up in the pace with the
pace of things and
I don't know I woke up one morning and I
was kind of feeling a little bit off and
I remember
um Catherine just asked me like
sweetheart are you okay
and I like completely just could not
stop crying I was like I'm okay I'm okay
um but she actually reminded me she's
like you know you care and that's that's
what makes you good and she's like and I
see you and you don't have to rush for
anybody you can take your time it's
really important that you feel strong
within yourself and that you allow
yourself the space to take a breath
because at the end of the day you know
she's like we love what we do and I
think that was really special of her to
say because it helped me pick myself
right back up
um she did it in her Catherine fashion
which I appreciate and love her for and
uh yeah it was a it was a really
eye-opening and um experience and a
great uh you know piece of advice from
her she makes me so happy to hear um all
right I have a game for you now it is
would you rather game I've got some
fairly silly questions here I'm gonna
start off with my favorite one it's very
silly would you rather have to fake
sneeze or fake vomit in a scene
uh I was probably fake vomit maybe uh I
think you know I always I grew up
watching Jim Carrey and his like like
he's really good at fake gagging and I
think when I was younger I was always
like how does he do that and I'd start
practicing so I think maybe like that's
so that's so crazy but yeah I feel like
maybe maybe that would be my choice I
have to ask now what's the go-to Jim
Carrey movie
The Mask oh wait but there's so many Fun
with Dick and Jane I'm a huge fan of his
I actually just barely watched The
Truman Show I know I'm so far behind on
that but uh he he was so brilliant in
that film and it definitely um is one of
my favorite movies now all excellent
choices please tell me you've seen Liar
Liar though of course I have one
thousand percent how to make sure all
right here's another silly one would you
rather have to eat a lot in a scene or
run a lot in a scene
oh
okay because I've heard horror stories
of people having to like eat
consistently in a scene
um and then like getting so sick from it
from my prior training uh throughout the
season of how much I had to run a lot
I'd say run a lot I've done it once
before let's do it again I was busy
thinking of that question there's a
scene early on in the uh in the season
where there's a pizza involved and I
kept thinking if I was anywhere near
that pizza and I was acting I'd be
totally screwed because I would I would
eat every slice no but listen it looks
delicious but in reality it's cold it's
soggy it's been sitting there all day
you do not want to eat it right all
right that I mean I am known to eat cold
pizza so I don't know if that would help
me but it's helpful yeah how about would
you rather work opposite someone who
improvises non-stop or work opposite
someone who sticks to the script and
never veers from it
oh
honestly
maybe somebody who's maybe someone who
sticks the script
um I think for me but like sticks to the
script that adds different uh takes on a
script so I'm kind of I'm leaning
towards both
um I hope that's an acceptable answer
but I do like when the great way of
cheating that question because they're
still sticking to the script that
they're giving like a like a different
feeler interpretation precisely yes I'm
gonna I'm gonna make fun of anyone who
doesn't realize that there's a loophole
to that one now
um would you rather play the killer in a
horror movie or get a really gnarly
death scene
oh my gosh I
I think I'd have a really gnarly dust
scene
um I've seen I've worked on a horror
movie before
um and it's I have yeah it was a the
name is not coming to me Pat healy's in
it and it's great it's really freaky um
we need to do something yeah that was my
first like yeah first film job ever um
but it was really a great experience to
get to see how horror functions and it's
an art form in itself I really respect
and
um yeah to be hooked up to like bloody
machines it's just so it's a long
process mad respect to people who like
horror is their genre
um yeah it was a lot of fun so I think
let's do it again you know I like the
sound of that and it gives me an excuse
to tell everyone watch National Treasure
and then also go watch uh
thank you that's a solid watch right
there
um I think I have to wrap with you soon
so let's try to end with this one maybe
so so it's not a would you rather
question but obviously like stealing is
bad we don't steal but let's say there
was one historical artifact out there
that would tempt you to go in and take
it what would it be
[Music]
um
well I would say I what during the
process of learning the history that we
talk about on the show
um I had learned that a lot of Mexico's
uh artifacts um are either lost or
they're somewhere in Europe so I think
it would be really cool
um you know to be able to retrieve some
of those artifacts like Montezuma's
feathers
um that you know I think Europe has
right now yeah it would be really cool
to do that back pocket that for future
Seasons maybe that's the question I like
season two it sounds very just like all
right I gotta let you go huge
congratulations on the show and thanks
so much for your time today thank you so
much I appreciate it